ахтем розкажіть що там із мобілізацією
у Росіян Так я знаєте
в'язниці народів точиться темабілізація
квітка агонія Путіна щоб
[музика]
провал операції
яким чином компенсувати
[музика]
Причому так
всіх і алкашів наркоманів та тюремників та
старих і молодих всіх, а от і кажеш про
Кавказ обливу про Крим у Криму
Так що там за розвивається діє
кримським татаром масового повістки ви
даєте не тільки хуртовини видають Он його
Він уламується в хати Він і там до нього
працюють люди та бюджетники входять і
вручають повістці
багатих шпали Прямо на вулиці та везли на
їх спецприймачами називаю Вони називають
збором пунктом збору призовників
призовники та вчора вже телефон і все
говорять волосся
цокають багатих щось виїхав з молодець і
знаєте
[музика]
та і 55 Роккі та 58
ніяких
німа там Якір градації про якований
намагаються сказати не вся брехня
колоборанти всіх там стукачі списки та за
раз
ми дві дві ночі вже намагаємося нашим до
допоміг ти виїхати через Казахстан через
Грузію
все знаєте
ось важимо руки ось та ціна за яку за раз
нашої плати те щоб вони не виїжджали з
Криму 1000 он і висимо руки ВК кричав і
саме ванни кричала Крим Україна
заріс помста і дай бог колаборантів і
подруга ну
я душа пірнаю чую ось тут димології
значить призватись до армії, а потім
здатися там десь Знайти можливість
Які зараз
старичкати а ось скількнеться година буде
все залежить знову таки видно наскільки
ми шви швитчі будемо
ламати Путіна та бандитську Росію
настільки
ванни повернутися сказ хоче їхати
туди лайка завершується у Грузії
Казахстані для того щоб
повернути і знову до Криму і ось тут
та 44
[музика]
сухопутні Шлях закриті
і тому ось на сьогодні тільки ось таким
можна росіян і масу випливають що там
трохи про черги на кордоні про росіян
я взяв бидло щось нічого сказати не хоче
він ще
десятки тисяч людей на скільки
ночі була така статистика менша
мільйонів
самі всі створили таку ситуацію
до такої ситуації привели, що ними
командуючи
золочениць цар а заріс
замистого щоб знати Ти в собі кістом
сваркам і потрібно
зламати Владу геть і цокають хто на
виборі насрали і тепер біжимо насрали
всім Гаразд
в Україну
[музика]
стікають цокають і здається яйця всієї
ситуації вивелося ательє у дагестанських
вінок бачив ці види
Хто добрий знає історію Дагестану всіх
30 рядки Росія за ту ж боялася
поєднанні
все було й у 90-х там
[музика]
багата національна територія там
мільйони
ногаїв
і тому
Росія завала там комфортно
нечисленні скажімо там групи
чекають на те ще Дагестан Може стати
будемо віспівати
знаєте ці процеси будуть закласти нас
кільки видно
три руки
чотири руки я кричущего Україна
успіх України
Росії
Російської Федерації
в болото машинський всі інші
волелюбні народи отримають шанс за
рахунок України та зітхнути та відійти від
цього буду ядерний ударчини
[музика]
шизофренік Путін
і будь-який спеціаліст лікар знає
я аналогію з Кримом
[музика]
сотні тисяч таких
цивільних
приїхали
автобусами чим могли до Криму, бо
прекрасний Крим та
почалася змія демографічного
стаєш у Криму Я не ракую фсбшників
[музика]
Прокурори
терористів Я говорю про так званий
цивільно на цілий день наїхали
сьогодні цифра вже більше мільйона Я говорю
а от
Херсон
з Росією загнати ось це ось цивільне
би на халяву яка звикла жити
[музика]
нових оккупованих територій більше
покладено на такі
категорію в керзових чоботях за іржавими
рушницями але
бидло Як
хоч із мушена але
вона
показує, що вона бидло їх будуть
примусово привозять туди стулки
рейдернутий приміщення там їх
засилають і намагання
контролювати
наша армія ось такі закидання Я сам
російський вибір
[музика]
характер провини йшли хто більше в
одному місці з купченовацією бідло ти тим
більше вони будуть
тому що
слава Україні